There is nothing in the world quite like Evo.
No esports tournament, no sporting event, no competition can compare to it.
After all, there’s no event in the world where everyone is a competitor.
Where everyone starts off on equal footing.
Where everyone gets a shot at glory.
(Casting)
Evo is the crucible where champions are made, but going 0-2 isn’t a curse.
It just means you have someone to root for.
Because on championship Sunday, the person who beat the person who beat the person who beat you
is up there, fighting to win it all.
The story of Evo is one of the competitors who show up every summer to prove their mettle.
It’s the story of a community fighting for their existence.
Fighting for the spirit of a community they all love.
Evo didn’t begin as the massive, 10,000-person juggernaut of a tournament that it is known
as today.
In the mid-’90s, the North American fighting game community was spread out across New York,
Northern California, Southern California and the midwest, but players rarely competed outside
of their regions.
Regional pride was strong though.
Arcades made for intense, close-quarters competition and the best player in the arcade
was a respected figure.
They were rulers of their domain, and always looking to expand their kingdom to other arcades.
And everyone wanted to take their spot.
"And you know if someone showed up to your arcade that you had never seen before, you guys
your crew had to make sure that they beat them because they were invaders and everything
like that and so there was just a lot of talk."
But people didn’t travel much for fighting
games back then.
There was no professional scene, no significant
prize pools.
Occasionally, one person went on vacation and ended up in another city’s arcade, and
then returned home to either talk trash or admit defeat.
That led to a lot of interregional trash talk on early internet message boards, without
much of a way to settle the score.
"And there was a lot of, well there was a lot of sh*t talking that went on right so."
At least not until Battle by the Bay.
1996’s Battle of the Bay was a chance to prove which region reigned supreme.
"The energy was pretty strong in there because it was really the first time that something like this
happened. There was a couple people who flew out from Kuwait, okay. But that was definitely very unique and
very surprising at the time."
The tournament was  a success, and inspired other, multi-regional
tournaments across the US.
Evo co-founders Tom Cannon, Tony Cannon, Joey Cuellar and Seth Killian didn’t see the
need for another Battle by the Bay until 2000 when they hosted the B4 championships.
Held in Folsom near Sacramento, B4 was bigger in every way.
but it was still held at a local arcade.
"I just remember there being a ton of people. I remember the place being hot as hell.
And I remember people just like chilling outside.
like just talking it up and stuff."
This time, it wasn’t the entire scene that needed help, it was the West coast.
Players from the East had the East Coast Championships as their mecca,
and while the West Coast’s
massive player base made for plenty of smaller tournaments in the wake of B3, there wasn’t
anything big enough to be a Major.
Then B5 hit the next year and the tournament grew again, bringing Japanese competitors
into the fray for the first time.
Everyone was still in Sacramento, which gave the locals a chance to see players they dreamed
of playing against.
"It was actually pretty unreal, like BAS I had heard of
BAS I had heard of for the first time in Alpha 3.
And someone had mentioned that he was coming to B5. And I like immediately lost my sh*t."
The small handful of Japanese players that showed up dominated the games they competed
in which marked the beginning of the B-series’ reputation as The tournament series.
No other US tournament had Japanese players in attendance.
And that was a big deal.
"I mean like I was saying before it was a huge deal when we'd heard that Japanese guys were coming
to compete at B5.
I was just like man Japanese players play Marvel 2 too?
Like I knew they played the main line Street Fighter games. But like I wanna see these guys
in action for Marvel 2. And that sort of brought it's own little intrigue."
But the arcade scene that birthed the Battle by the Bay tournaments was dying, fast.
By 2002, Southern Hills Golfland would close,
and arcades all across North America were going out of business.
The competitive environment that created fighting game communities all around the world was going away
in the states,
and the crew behind B3, 4 and 5 wanted to find a way to preserve it.
Enter the Evolution Championship Series, or Evo for short.
Evo was meant to preserve the spirit of the arcade,
even if the arcades themselves were
going away.
"We talk about arcade culture and some people think about racing games or skeeball or something
like that. That's not the part of arcade culture that we cared about.
We care about like the tournaments that were happening, all over the country
And that we really love and wanted to save.
And that's why we made EVO."
Though, it wasn’t always going to be called Evo.
Plenty of names were through around, including Apex, Riot Zone and….
FightCon.
Evo 2002 was held in a UCLA campus in Pomona, and the organizers rented arcade machines
from local arcades.
When they realized they’d only have enough machines for the tournament and none for free-play,
they had to get creative with the event structure.
"And we wanted to turn the event, not just into a tournament, but
turn it into a little bit of a show. So that's where Sunday comes from.
Let's run all the tournaments, until the Top 8. And then we'll run the Top 8, The very best of the best,
back to back to back to back on Sunday. And it'll be a show, it'll be an experience, everybody will love it
and they'll stick around.
And that's where the idea of like Top 8 comes from. It's literally that."
By Evo 2003, there were more than 300 people in attendance.
It was easily the largest fighting game tournament ever, and the sheer amount of attendees was
getting harder and harder to manage.
On top of that, the death of the arcade scene was beginning to impact Evo in other ways.
"The more EVO scaled up to have more players participate in it. The more need you
have to make that sustainable. And because the game was already on console, it only made sense."
The move to consoles was controversial to say the least.
If Evo was about preserving the spirit of the arcade, many assumed the hardware would
obviously follow.
"The reaction to the console switch was not good.
I mean it was almost universally reviled.
You know likepeople were mad."
But the mid-2000s were something of a dark age for plenty of Japanese fighting games,
particularly Capcom fighters, the backbone of Evo in its early years.
And few console ports, if any, were considered “arcade perfect” for Capcom’s games.
"At that point in time after third strike there just really wasn't much happening."
"I think that a lot of people forget that, and a lot of people just don't realise that that was reality
Where we really didn't feel like another new thing thing was coming out."
Evo’s move to consoles wasn’t smooth for the tournament, as Street Fighter 3: Third
Strike didn’t have a console port that was even close to tournament-ready, so the Evo
2004 3S tournament was run on arcade hardware.
But the controversy was quickly swept under the rug when the tournament produced some
of Evo’s most memorable moments.
In what has now become one of the most iconic esports moments of all time, Justin Wong and
Daigo Umehara, two titans in the scene, faced off in the losers’ finals of Evo 2004’s
Third Strike tournament.
Justin took a commanding lead in the last round of the first game,
and it seemed like he was going to go up a game in a key set.
With Daigo’s back to the wall, Justin bet that Daigo couldn't
parry every hit of Chun’s Hoyoku-sen Super.
He bet that Daigo couldn’t execute 15 frame perfect inputs in a row with all the pressure
in the world on him.
He was wrong.
Daigo perfectly parried and punished Justin’s super and won the round, then the game.
"You know everyone kept talking about how great he is and everything like that,
But the Daigo parry was that one moment where it happened.
And it happened in front of a bunch of people and it was ridiculous."
Evo moment 37 was everything Evo was supposed to be.
It was a display of pure skill, under immense pressure, with a crowd just inches away from the players.
After that, Evo organizers and members of the fighting game community realized things like EVO moment
37, which went viral on a young YouTube, could turn Evo into an ambassador, helping to grow
the fighting game community.
But Evo 2004 was also messy at times.
In the SoulCalibur II Grand Finals, RTD and Mick played a pretty low-quality grand finals
and allegedly split the pot.
"It was obvious from anyone who plays fighting games, they were playing different characters and were
playing at a very subpar level."
The incident led Evo to create their first collusion rule, yet another attempt to preserve
the spirit of true, arcade-era competition.
"We should look into that for next year, cause we need to solve this problem."
2005 presented another opportunity for growth as the tournament moved from California to
Las Vegas thanks in part to a partnership with Major League Gaming.
But the partnership wasn’t exactly equal.
"At the time, EVO was bigger than MLG
in a way, and in fact, they kinda tagged along with us.
You know it was kind of a big deal."
Evo and MLG split the venue, one half for Evo’s fighting games, and the other half
for MLG Halo and Smash tournaments.
But Evo brought way more players to the tournament, leaving them without any space in their corner.
Meanwhile MLG’s tournaments pulled in a quarter of what Evo did.
It wasn’t pretty.
"When Halo was at EVO. Oh my god they had Halo at EVO right in the middle of the ballroom.
And after the Halo tournament, one of the Cannon brothers goes on the megaphone
and goes. "We'd like to congratulate Team whatever..." What was the team? "Team Liquid or some sh*t right?
Because they're the winners of the Halo tournament."
And right when he said that, everyone in the whole room boo'd the sh*t out of them."
And MLG has never partnered with Evo since.
By 2006 Evo was big enough to get Capcom’s seal of approval, and even a Toyota sponsorship
that let the tournament go on the road with Evo East and Evo West.
It also led them to include a racing game on the roster for the first, and last time.
"When Toyota became a sponsorship they wanted at least, one ra- like something to do with driving
at EVO so. They wanted something and so they basically picked Mario Kart DS cause it was going to be an easy
way to add that in to the schedule.
But at Evo East, the tournament hit a snag.
EVO needed CRT TVs, since more modern TVs would introduce too much lag.
But their supplier could only offer them LCD and Plasma TVs a day before the tournament
started.
Things got dicey.
Someone overheard the conversation about the TVs and immediately went to the Shoryuken
forums to say that the tournament was ruined before and that people should stay at home.
The Evo organizers found a way, loading 32 CRT TVs into a truck in the middle of the night
and working to put on a good event.
Or they were going to, until they realized the truck was broken.
“Tony, who’s in the truck with Gilbert gets on the horn to me when we're about half way through.
And says to me, "Uh Tom there's a situation with the truck."
I'm like "Okay? Is everything alright?"
He's like "Well? Gilbert tells me that uh, the clutch on the truck is blown out.
and so that means that if this truck ever stops, uh it's not gonna start again until we fix it."
It's 3am we're on the highway, we're fifty miles from home, and the truck cannot stop.
Right? It's like Speed,
So we get a few miles down the road ahead of them  and we get to the toll road,
and Seth is driving, and he rolls into the toll. And he rolls down the window.
says, "There's a truck behind us, and it can't stop."
He's like, "It's not out of control, it's a safe situation. But the truck behind us, is not going to stop at this toll."
The tolls is like two dollars, he says, "Here's 20 dollars, this is for us, and the truck behind us."
And he doesn't even wait for a response he gives the twenty dollars and he just rolls up the window
he just like, there we go.
They rolled into the toll, and they slowed down as much as they could. And as they're approaching the toll
Gilbert and the attendant sort of had this connection, where their eyes locked.
And the attendant was like "Are you the truck?" And Gilbert is like, "Yes I'm the truck."
And they're getting closer and the gate raised. And they go through and you know we made it right?"
2001 marked the beginning of Justin Wong’s four-year Marvel vs. Capcom 2 Evo streak that
would go on to define Marvel at Evo for the rest of the decade.
Justin won every Evo MvC2 tournament between
2001 and 2004.
After that, he won three more in 2006, 2008 and 2010, MvC2’s last year at the tournament.
"Justin Wong takes it, first and last EVO Marvel vs Capcom 2 Champion."
"He seals it up."
In that time though, plenty of fighters attempted to match Justin’s incredible run.
In 2005, Duc Do, the first Evo MvC2 champion at B4, broke the streak by taking first place
with some unorthodox Spiral play.
In 2007, despite Justin’s extraordinary comeback against Yipes in losers’
"Justin Wong, oh my god."
Yipes still managed to bring home  the win.
In 2009, Sanford Kelly, long considered to be one of the East Coast’s finest Marvel
players brought down Justin in the Grand Finals to etch his own name into history.
"Sanford Kelly, he finally wins."
But Justin’s performance at the final Evo MvC2 tournament in 2010 was something of a sign.
History had spoken and it said that Justin Wong was the greatest Marvel 2 player to ever
touch the game.
But though Marvel 2 and a variety of Street Fighter games were the backbone of Evo for
years, both games were starting to feel a little stale
by the mid-2000s.
The hype from a small community built around a dying genre and out-of-date consoles wasn’t
sustaining Evo.
There were plenty of attempts to bring people into the tournament, including adding new
games and rotating out old ones.
That’s how the story of Super Smash Bros. Melee at Evo began.
Melee first appeared at Evo in 2007, with Ken taking first place,
cementing his status as the best Melee player in the world at the time.
But 2007 was also the last time Melee would appear at Evo for the foreseeable future.
In 2008, Melee was replaced by Brawl, which the tournament organizers ran with items on
and a bizarre stage selection process that led CPU, a complete unknown, to defeat Ken
in the grand finals.
"CPU, your Smash Bros. Brawl EVO 2k8 champion. Make some noise."
The Brawl tournament soured plenty of Smash players on Evo, and neither game officially returned in 2009."
2007’s eight games gave way to just six in the next year, making it the smallest Evo lineup
since 2002.
In some people’s eyes, the shrinking crowds and smaller number of games, were all pointing
to one thing:
Evo was dying, and the arcade scene they were striving to preserve would die along with it.
"In 2008 I still remember at one point looking around the room and going, "I know like
almost everybody here. Like I'm not seeing new faces." It just felt like there was a peak at some point.
And you know even the MvC 2  was the strongest game for a while. At that point Third Strike was the strongest
game but it just didn't feel. It just didn't have that same pizzazz to it I don't know I can't explain it."
But  there was a small glimmer of hope.
At EVO 2008, Capcom gave fans a chance to play their first new fighting game in years:
Street Fighter IV.
Street Fighter IV had been announced months before, and had been available in Japanese
arcades, but Evo 2008 was one of the first times that the North American FGC got their
hands on the game that could save their scene.
Street Fighter IV was designed to be a return to form, but more importantly, it was the
first numbered Street Fighter game since 3S in 1999.
It was proof that Capcom still cared about this community that was born out of Street
Fighter II all those years ago.
In fact, Street Fighter IV was designed to play similarly to Street Fighter II.
It removed some of the more complicated mechanics
introduced in the Street Fighter Alpha and
III in favor of more straightforward
play, meant to encourage lapsed fans back
into the fold.
It worked.
Evo went from a few hundred players in 2008 to a 1,000-person Street Fighter IV bracket in 2009.
It brought the scene back to life.
"I remember almost kinda sitting in that chair, jaw on the floor, just eyes wide open."
"Did this really just happen?"
"It was the most insane experience that I ever had and probably only the second time in my life
the first time being the Daigo parry moment, that I sat down and I was like, this could be a thing."
"As soon as 2009 happened I was like, I can't go I have to stay, I have to ride this out."
In a perfect twist of fate, Daigo played Justin Wong in the first ever Evo Street Fighter
IV Grand Finals, calling back to their famous showdown five years earlier.
"It felt like it was, fate that brought them in the grand finals."
"And it felt like there was really no chance maybe for Justin to win but then he reset the bracket."
"And I still remember how crazy the audience was going and this was the biggest the audience crowd had
ever been."
(Casting)
Daigo’s win kicked off a new era for Evo, but perhaps more importantly, it kicked off
a new era for the FGC.
The quality of the match itself, the intensity of the set and the thrill of being part of
a 1,000 player bracket kicked the tournament into high gear.
Thanks in part to Street Fighter IV, Evo has never looked back.
It’s grown, year over year, to unbelievable heights.
But Street Fighter isn’t the only reason Evo has gotten so huge.
The tournament struggled through the hard times to come out the other side, to a world
where just one game didn’t have to carry the whole FGC.
Evo 2009 was the biggest Evo yet.
But they were just getting started.
"Hadouken!"
"Continue?"
"Nine!"
"Eight!"
"So big for Hungrybox right now this is his moment."
"Seven!"
"Six!"
"Five!"
"Oh my god! He takes it!"
"Four!"
"Three!"
"Two!"
"What are you standing up for!"
"Why! Why!"
"Oh my god!"
"One!"